- Welcome back y'all.
(audience applauds)
We've got Charlie Day
and Ken Jeong with us.
Give it up.
(audience applauds)
Their new movie which is in theaters now,
is called "Fool's Paradise".
So, it is time to see if we can fool them.
Like what we did there?
With a pop song trivia game.
This is "Pop Pop Quiz".
(upbeat music)
♪ Pop, pop quiz ♪
(audience applauds)
(Kelly chuckles)
Okay, it's...
(Kelly laughs)
I love, okay, It's me
versus Charlie versus Ken.
And here to host please welcome,
friend of the show and a man you can see
alongside Seth Rogen and Rose Burn
in the upcoming Apple TV Plus series,
"Platonic", Guy Branum.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
- Hello, Kelly.
Thank you so much for having me back.
- We love you.
- [Guy] I love being here.
(Kelly chuckles)
We do have to address one thing though.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Charlie, last time you were here
you lost a game that I was hosting.
Are you prepared to redeem yourself?
- No, I lose most games and imagine
that I will lose again today,
but I will try.
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay.
- Give it your best effort.
- And then fail miserably
so we can enjoy it.
(group laughs)
- Thank you.
- Here's how the game works.
I'll read a trivia question,
the answer to that question is hidden
in the lyrics of a popular song.
So if I asked,
how white was Mary's Little Lamb's fleece?
You might answer...
(buzzer dings)
- White as snow.
- Kelly Clarkson.
- [Guy] Exactly.
(bell rings)
- I might be good at this.
- Wow.
(audience applauds)
- I might be good at this.
- That's a competitor right there.
- Yeah.
- If either Ken or Charlie wins,
their photo will go up on the
"Chicks Wall of Champions
Who Beat Kelly Clarkson".
(audience applauds)
- Whoo.
- Are you ready?
- No, no.
(Kelly chuckles)
- All right, question one.
- Okay.
- When the B-52's were in their Chrysler,
big as a whale, how
many people did it seat?
(buzzer dings)
- [Guy] Kelly Clarkson?
- Fits about 20 and...
(bell rings)
- Kelly Clarkson's right.
- Yeah!
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my God.
- I might be good at this.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
- What kind of car was that if it fits 20?
♪ Fits about 20 ♪
- Were you thrown off by my spot on,
Fred Schneider impression?
- Yes, I was, I was.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was thrown off by how
big that car is, 20 people?
- A lot of people.
- Question two.
- Okay.
- What would Gloria Gaynor have changed
if she knew for one second
you'd be back to bother her?
- I know the lyrics, but...
(buzzer dings)
♪ Back to bother ♪
Would've changed your
stupid locks, I would've...
(bell rings)
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- [Guy] Two points for Kelly Clarkson.
(Kelly screams)
(audience applauds)
- Wait a second...
- I'm feeling good fellas.
- You are...
- I'm feeling good.
- I didn't even understand the sentence.
- [Ken] I didn't know.
(Kelly laughs)
- I was like, that was...
(Charlie sighs)
- Change those stupid locks, I should...
(Kelly hums)
- Can we do another game?
(group laughs)
- I don't write them, I was told them.
- All right, all right.
- Question three,
in her latest single Miley Cyrus
started to cry until she remembered what?
(buzzer dings)
♪ I can buy myself flowers ♪
(bell rings)
(audience applauds)
♪ Write my name in the sand ♪
- [Kelly] Yeah.
♪ Talk to myself for hours ♪
It's a good, it's a jam y'all, it's a jam.
- [Charlie] That's, that's good, yeah.
- It's a good song.
- I was gonna guess
that she was dehydrated
and she couldn't cry.
(group laughs)
But you know.
- That happens.
- And I would've given her IV fluids,
because I'm a doctor, but.
(Guy laughs)
(buzzer dings)
What's the, why'd you buzz that?
Why did you buzz that?
(Kelly chuckles)
- [Guy] It's a respectable skill.
Next time you have Ken on, let him come on
and do an appendectomy
for the audience, okay?
- Thank you, something I can perform.
- [Kelly] I do need IV fluids.
- Question four, question four.
The Righteous Brothers
and Hall and Oats claimed,
you'd lost that loving feeling,
because the tenderness was gone
from what part of your body?
(buzzer dings)
Charlie Day?
- Your heart?
- No sorry.
- No, it...
- Ken Jeong.
- It was gone, gone, gone,
from your whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nailed it, nailed it.
- One Point, one point to Ken Jeong.
(audience applauds)
- Nailed it, nailed it.
- [Guy] We were looking...
(bell rings)
- Nailed it.
(audience applauds)
- [Guy] We were looking for fingertips.
- [Ken] Nailed it.
- But we'll accept your whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Nailed it.
- I couldn't...
- That's medically accurate.
♪ On your fingertips ♪
- I couldn't...
- No one remembers that.
- I couldn't remember that.
- No, no one knows that,
fingertips don't exist medically.
Whoa, whoa, whoa is an
organ in your abdomen.
(group laughs)
All right.
- Question five, question five.
What did Lizzo's DNA test reveal?
(buzzer dings)
- A hundred percent that bitch, what?
(bell rings)
(audience applauds)
- Wow, there you go.
- [Guy] Beautiful work.
We have a score of Kelly a lot.
(Kelly chuckles)
Ken, a sympathy point.
- Yes.
- [Guy] Charlie Day, still
nothing on the board.
- I know.
(Kelly laughs)
No, is it a golf thing
where the lowest score wins?
(group laughs)
(soft music)
It's not that? Okay.
- [Kelly] We can filter it.
(soft music)
- All right, that sound indicates
it's time for our last question.
But you guys, this question
is worth seven points
so it's still anyone's game.
(audience gasps)
- Oh, I'm gonna win.
I'm gonna win, I'm gonna win.
(Kelly hums)
(Kelly laughs)
I'm gonna win.
- [Guy] Kelly, you ready?
- Yes, I am.
- [Guy] Charlie, are you ready?
- No, no.
- [Guy] All right, question six.
What did I hear through the grapevine?
♪ Ooh, you imagine ♪
(buzzer dings)
- [Guy] Charlie Day.
- I heard it through the grapevine.
I heard it through the grapevine.
(buzzer dings)
- I will accept that, I will accept that.
(bell rings)
(audience applauds)
- Through the grapevine.
- You won, you won dude.
He won, so good.
- And I'm just...
- So good.
- I'm just about to loose my mind.
- We were looking for,
"Not much longer would you be mine".
But I would say technically...
- No.
- You did hear it through the grapevine.
- I heard it through the grapevine.
(buzzer dings)
(audience applauds)
- Nicely done.
- Thank you.
- Nice recovery.
- So good.
- I couldn't predict that.
- I'm so sorry.
It was fair and square.
(Kelly laughs)
So, sorry.
- Congratulations.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, I totally deserve that.
- You said it.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks for playing y'all.